allez on ouvre à présent notre page
consacrée aux conséquences du
coronavirus sur nos vies il y a un an la
plupart des salariés découvrez le
télétravail ou le chômage partiel en
restant chez eux
à la demande du gouvernement sans main
d'oeuvre en présentiel et sans
perspectives
les entreprises ont dû s'adapter pour
continuer leurs activités dans un
contexte économique inédit focus ce soir
sur deux sociétés qui ont su
temporairement se réinventer pour
surmonter la crise du coc vide les cas
chopin c'était un coup de massue il y a
un an sonné l'heure du confinement
forçant l'entreprise tourangelle le chat
à se réinventer pour pallier les 70 % de
contrats en moins sept sociétés
d'impression avait créé des panneaux de
plexiglas à destination des entreprises
une année après le chat fabrique bien
moins de panneaux qu'avant et continue à
s'adapter
aujourd'hui encore des commerçants qui
ne sont pas équipés parce que de se dire
que ça allait durer plus d'un an
personne ne voyez ça du tout donc on
continue encore d'en faire mais je
dirais cinq fois moins qu'avant mais
aujourd'hui on essaye aussi d'aller vers
d'autres produits qui peuvent rendre
service pour nos clients on a des
pochettes à masquer que ce soit le mas
comme celui que j'ai là où le masque en
tissu aussi nous nous étions également
rendu chez alter paint entreprises loir
et chérienne de peinture industrielle
qui s'était gracieusement lancer dans la
fabrication de gel hydroalcoolique
quelques 10 tonnes de gel plus tard
l'entreprise a largement baissé sa
production en raison d'une demande moins
importante altèrent paint a par ailleurs
reçu le prix entreprise remarquable du
loir et cher grâce à sa bonne action
et si c'était à refaire mais on
recommencerait bien entendu c'est sûr et
même plus si on peut
ça nous semblait être un geste solidaire
extrêmement important
aujourd'hui on sait que ce confinement
et cette situation a surpris tout le
monde
il fallait réagir on a considéré que
c'était notre part de faire ce genre
d'action désormais halter paint a
retrouvé son activité principale de
manière soutenue le ch a quant à lui
continue de s'orienter vers une
production adapté aux virus